thousands of iraqis turned out in
baghdad's green zone for a friday mass
prayer and protest
they're mostly supporters of influential
shayt leader mukhtar assad
some in the crowd call it a revolution
iraq has been controlled by corrupt
politicians through consecutive
governments the quota system resulted in
the deterioration of the health care
system education and security poverty is
on the rise but corrupt officials get
richer every day drugs and weapons are
spread everywhere because of those
authoritarian parties affiliated to
foreign powers
many have traveled here from different
parts of iraq
in the hopes of getting their voices
heard
iraq has had only a caretaker government
for the last nine months
and many basic services have been
interrupted
is
[Music]
sunni kurds christians and yazidis
all to say no to the constitution
drafted by the americans we will not
leave until parliament is dissolved
these protesters highlight the months of
political style made to form a
government since last october's general
elections
southern supporters have been occupying
parliament in protest
in a televised statement souther urges
his supporters to continue their sit-in
and suggested dissolving parliament and
holding early elections as a solution to
the political deadlock
the prayers coincide with other
supporters leaving the parliament
building after a one-week sit-in
but they have been instructed to stay on
the ground surrounding parliament
we are planning to continue here until
we topple the regime no matter what it
takes
we have nothing to lose more than what
we have already lost
our country is in ruins
the un special representative to iraq
janine plus heart has met mukhtar
in najaf
she's been quoted by local media as
saying the meeting was productive
but some of sadr's rival politicians
pose a challenge including former prime
minister nuri al-maliki and the head of
the popular mobilization forces falhel
fayyad
both men insist holding early elections
requires the formation of a new
government
because iraq's caretaker government
doesn't have the legal right to hold
another election
which means millions of iraqis may be
facing many more days of uncertainty
a